logistically this film was incredibly
complicated we had a massive amount of
equipment that we had to move halfway
around the world
just getting gear in and out of Borneo
takes extraordinary amount of time
today's the day of our big epic move of
river basically production is
replicating bootys journey to camp
Leakey 40 years ago except this time we
are bringing 15 votes with us 15,000
pounds of production equipment we got
seven trucks here unloading them you
have about 50 people below us who are
putting it all the other boat drivers
and cooks and porters and whole
production crew we're going to be living
on traditional boats for the next 10
days it's going to be an amazing journey
I'm really happy to be heading up
angeleka where it all began tonight
o'clock in the morning on the Suwannee
River and today is what we call the
tennis hot and notice the sweat and wet
spots on everyone's shirt it's really
hot
a few hours a washout time delay we've
assembled one of the best crews in the
world for this kind of film because when
you see the equipment we're working with
it's way beyond what's done in any other
documentary the most precise elements
all have to come together to make these
shots work the movies primary piece of
equipment was a state-of-the-art IMAX 3d
film camera which weighs over 250 pounds
for this particular IMAX film however
that alone would not be enough every
project has its range of technical
challenges for this film we did indeed
build a tower first digital 3d camera
we've been able to capture things that
you could never get on film they're
scenes that happen in a fast way
you can't do take two you have to be
there and ready
the more versatile IMAX 3d digital
camera was able to capture spontaneous
animal behavior and was essential during
an unexpected event in Kenya a situation
came up while we here at salvo
where a young elephant was spotted with
a herd of bulls we were there in the
middle of this very crazy rodeo type
scene where they had to separate this
little tiny elephant from the big bulls
we got all that footage in IMAX 3d which
is phenomenal
there are no trained animals in this
film you know these are all animals that
have been born wild they're all animals
that are going to be wild we can show up
and we can get all the permits and the
visas we need but we can't make any
animal do anything what we would do is
we would just set up and then sure
enough some elephant would come over or
some larger hanging Chad would come
along and do something really
extraordinary the things that we filmed
we never thought we'd sell
you